- So our opening image would include the house and stuff?
- Yeah.
- And the cars...
When the sun moves we’ll get this.
It’s going to be great.
It's going to be great. Beautiful.
We should also do it tighter
when she just announces her name.
Okay.
- You got it?
-Yes, yes.
We’ll do the medium first, ok?
Excellent.
Ok, perfect.
When he gets in here, they're doing that
in the background.
Maybe even at the end
where he goes “Ooh, jeeze.”
As it goes over,
it’ll be higher off the ground.
- Right.
- And down.
Why don’t you sit up?
Yeah.
Yeah, that's what it is.
Okay.
Yeah.
It could work, yeah.
The two shot is just not going to work.
We want to be on them.
It's just going to be like...
Who cares?
It doesn't.
It's got to be here
and here again.
He did! With the wings and
people will go and they’ll watch as a guy flies.
He was onto something, though.
Yes he was.